it's crazy that the last time I talked
about Godfrey was seven months ago and
my Like father-like Son video where we
discussed the complicated relationship
between Godfrey and his Omen son morgot
our fight with him is a defining moment
in the game and he is the last thing
standing in the way from us finally
understanding what Waits inside the urge
tree since we as a tarnish were brought
back to the lands between we have had
one purpose to seek the Elden ring and
mend it back together but we aren't the
only tarnish to return or a Lou gold
Mass FIA dung eater and Gideon just to
name a few have also been brought back
to the lands between now the question
I'd like to ask today is why were these
individuals brought back that could make
for a huge video which really isn't my
style today let's focus on Godfrey also
known as horalu and discuss his journey
intentions and honestly where he might
have been all this time leading up to
our fight with him at the foot of the
herd tree make sure to like subscribe
all that good YouTube stuff I'm trying
to upload more often to get back in the
good graces of the algorithm Gods before
DLC is announced so if you'd like to see
more videos and give joy some more tummy
rubs I'd appreciate it with all that
said let's talk about Godfrey the first
Elden Lord
long and hard did slow fight
tarnished Warrior
spurned by the grace of gold be assured
the Elden ring
resteth close at hand
I've always wondered why Godfrey tells
us this for us to be assured that the
Elden ring is nearby the definition of
spurned is the past tense of spurn which
is to reject with disdain or contempt
makes me wonder if he knows our intent
more than we actually do since he was
our leader at one point or another do we
both have disdain for the Elden ring
since its guidance of Grace was taken
away from us and we were banished from
the lands between maybe we want revenge
or to prove to Queen America and the
golden order that we do deserve its
Grace once again so I guess Godfrey
assuring us that the Eldon ring is
nearby makes sense because at this point
in the game no one knows where Queen
America is and in turn the Eldon ring
since she is the vassal for the Elden
ring itself Godfrey is tarnished as well
we can see from the opening cut scene
that he died outside the lands between
just as it was prophesized by Queen
America herself in America's own words
my Lord
and thy Warriors
I divest each of thee of thy Grace
With Thine Eyes dimmed ye will be driven
from the lands between ye will wage war
in a land afar
where you will live
and die so Godfrey must have been
brought back or given his guidance back
for the same purpose as us to restore
the Elden ring he's definitely strong
enough to defeat all the demigod Shard
bearers who have refused to return to
the archery and mend back the Eldon ring
they've all refused to do this for their
own individual reasons but why were we a
tarnished of no Renown at all we're
having the most success against the
demigods were we the only tarnish to
actually tried were we just the first
one to each Shard Bearer answering these
questions is pretty much impossible time
definitely doesn't feel relative in the
lands between it's almost like different
time frames have compressed into one
another hovering the world in ruin mixed
with creatures and beings from different
ages making the lands between a sort of
purgatory sorry I'm probably thinking
too deep about this at least for this
video so when Godfrey says the words
spurned by the grace of gold it reminds
me of godric's dialogue that seemed to
be obsessed with his forefathers and
having them witness what he has done and
what he has become
yes great Godfrey It's thou witness I am
the Lord
of all that is golden
and one day
we'll return together
to our home
bathed in Rays of gold so what is this
home bathed in Rays of gold exactly well
I think we can learn exactly where from
this Ghost spirit located just outside
the fourth Church of America in the
Weeping peninsula where he says oh there
it is the tower finally I can return to
our home bathed and raised of gold now
for the longest time I thought this
ghost was looking at the wandering
Mausoleum and suggesting that a home
bathed in Rays of gold had something to
do with the afterlife of some kind but
looking closer the ghost is referring to
and staring directly at a tower at the
top of the hill which is conveniently
called the Tower of return if you climb
to the top and open the trap chest you
will be sent to the Divine Bridge side
of Grace inside the Royal capital city
of landel which must be what this ghost
in godric we're referring to as their
home bathed in rays of gold now I've
wanted to mention this for some time but
just haven't found the right moment to
do so but doesn't the city's design look
kind of fake in a way for example the
gold paint on the rooftops of Landell is
chipping off sort of like it has been
painted on and not actually gold it's
very interesting and could play into the
discussion that the golden order isn't
as strong as they try to portray
themselves to be I think that's the main
theme of Corin and gold mask questline
but this could be something for us to
discuss in another video in regards to
Godfrey he has done everything he can to
become the Elden Lord based on his own
words becoming Elden Lord is warranted
with strength and Godfrey is pretty much
the perfect strength build heavy armor
heavy ax heavy attacks where he can
quite literally Smash down and pull up
the Earth around him he's dedicated his
entire life to being the strongest
Warrior and conducting himself as a
worthy Lord Godfrey's icon says that
when he vowed to become a lord he took
the Beast Regent sarash upon his back to
suppress the ceaseless lust for battle
that raged within his armor set says
that he led the war against the Giants
and faced the stormlord alone Godfrey
battled anyone and everyone who opposed
the golden order and once his last great
enemy fell the Hue from Godfrey's eyes
faded his guidance of Grace was taken
away from him there was no one left to
fight so Queen America banished him and
his Warriors from the lands between I
believe she did this so that they could
continue to find and fight worthy
opponents that seems to be the life of a
warrior with Grace or not the
remembrance of horlu says that when
Godfrey first Elden Lord was robbed of
his grace becoming tarnished he took
with him his Kinfolk and left the lands
between after the long march of the
tarnish came to an end Godfrey divested
himself of kingship becoming a simple
Warrior once more what I take from this
and for you this may be different is
that the golden order didn't need
Godfrey's strength anymore since all of
the worthy opponents had been defeated I
believe it was at this point that Queen
America started to question the golden
order's intentions and started to test
its own strength I declare my intent
to search the depths of the golden order
through understanding of the proper way
our faith our Grace is increased those
Blissful early days of blind belief are
long past eventually as we all know we
America shattered the Elden ring
spreading shards of its power throughout
the lands between and during the
shattering War the strongest were able
to obtain great runes that they use for
their own purposes maybe this was Queen
America's true intention when shattering
the Elden ring to test the world's Faith
toward it and see what those who claim
their allegiance to the golden order
would actually do when its power was
truly tested I'm coming up with a lot of
other video ideas while making this one
aren't I hear me demigods my children
beloved make of thy selves that which he
desire
be it a lord
be it a God but should he fail to become
old at all
you will be forsaken a mounting only to
sacrifices so this is the point I'm
starting to understand about honestly
the entire game it's all a challenge
that's all the golden order the Elden
ring the guidance of Grace the greater
will whatever you want to refer to it as
once where does the guidance of Grace
Point us toward the entire game a
challenge not even necessarily towards A
Shard Bearer Grace points us toward
Castle Morton as an example to fight
against a misbegotten and receive a
sword a challenge nonetheless but not
really toward anything of great
importance in the grand scheme of it all
however this is the only time it does go
off course from The Shard bearers so I
don't know if that's enough to fully
state that it's all for the challenge of
battle but even so even if they are A
Shard Bearer it's all a massive
challenge to overcome if the Rays of
Grace signal the castle then the Elden
ring beckons you as an ally by Pact
I pray that you are fit to face the
challenge presented by the ring
forgive me
I've been testing you to determine if
the Elden ring would truly have you if
you had the metal to endure this long
and arduous path it seems my worries
were unfounded torrent had your measure
from the very start this all reminds me
of Godfrey and his entire relationship
with the golden order he battled for the
golden order until there was nothing
left to fight against as soon as all of
his worthy enemies fell the Hue faded
from his eyes and he was no longer
needed I believe it is possible that if
becoming Elden Lord is truly warranted
with strength then guidance of Grace is
simply seeking out discourse or other
challenges in battle to become a
Victorious Warrior Grace shows the
tarnish where they can find glory and
strength in battle it points to all
forms of challenge to either die or
obtain more power maybe it's simply a
way of living for a warrior and our
final test is against Godfrey himself at
the foot of the earth tree but where was
Godfrey this entire time why is he just
now coming back to the ERD tree well I
don't think he was alive until now he
was likely still in the Badlands where
he battled over and over again as a
normal Warrior until he finally fell
which is what I believe is being
depicted in this painting in the opening
cinematic Grace was waiting for a worthy
opponent for Godfrey to fight against
and prove his strength to Queen America
in the golden order once again they gave
Godfrey his guidance of Grace back he
came back to the lands between and as
soon as Godfrey sees his now fallen son
morgot the guidance of Grace changes its
direction to point directly at us we are
here to be Godfrey's new challenge we
both have the same intention to brandish
the Elden ring but there can only be one
Elden Lord and we must battle against
each other Crown is warranted with
strength and we must prove it to not
only the golden order but to ourselves
as a tarnished Warrior as those who seek
to become the new Elden Lord who is the
strongest in the lands between and who
deserves to enter the urge tree and seek
audience with Queen America to brandish
the Elden ring in any way that we see
fit and this entire situation is created
by the challenge that the guidance of
Grace seeks or all of the tarnished alas
I am returned to be granted audience
once more
upon my name as Godfrey
the first Elden Lord
[Music]
[Music]